i'm going to talk today about
thought vectors knowledge graphs and the
curious death of keyword search
so the agenda for today
is
pretty simple it's the title of the talk
we're going to talk about thought
vectors we're going to talk about
knowledge graphs and then we're going to
talk about keyword search and how
thought vectors and knowledge graphs
replace or augment a keyword search
so to get started
you know before we started talking about
thought vectors and what they really are
which i'll get into in just a minute
we had keyword search so this as many of
you will be familiar with is an example
of an inverted index where i have
documents uh
the documents have keywords in them so
for in this example the word apple the
word donut and the word juice are all
terms that appear within these documents
and then we pre-index
a
mapping of every possible keyword into a
postings list of documents that that
keyword appears within so that when
somebody searches for the you know the
search apple juice we look up apple find
all the documents it's in look up juice
find all the documents that contain
juice and then do a set intersection and
ultimately find all of the documents
that contain the words apple and juice
from there you know this is the standard
bm25 formula which i won't get into but
we essentially take every document and
we score it relative to those terms
apple and juice to try to figure out
which documents are the most related to
the query that comes in this is
traditional keyword search most folks
watching this
presentation are probably very familiar
with with this technique
of course
you know in recent years
there's been a
massive
effort to improve search and bert which
many of you have probably heard about is
google's attempt that they've actually
rolled out into their search engine uh
to do so and so this is the article from
when bert was first released in google
search results
and just to give you a sense the article
says google is making one of the biggest
changes to its ranking algorithm as it
gives artificial intelligence a
deepening role in the world's most
popular search engine the change which
google described as its most significant
revision in at least five years uses a
new form of language analysis to
understand users queries better
it is set to until now google's
algorithm has tried to single out the
most important words in any search
ignoring smaller or common words that
seem less significant this enables it to
zero in on the main subject but often
results in it misunderstanding its
precise request the new technique known
as bert relies on language model built
up from analysis of vast amounts of text
online rather than reading a string of
search words sequentially it analyzes
them all at the same time including
smaller words that would have been
ignored before
one example google gave of the types of
questions it could now handle was how
old was taylor swift when kanye jumped
on the stage
this points to more complex queries that
have been beyond its reach before the
update marks the first application of a
piece of research on natural language
processing from last year that has drawn
considerable attention in ai circles
and so i keep mentioning thought vectors
what are thought vectors you've probably
heard the word embeddings before
but there's many kinds of embeddings so
thought vectors encompass all of those
kinds so for example you can have a word
or phrase embedding that essentially
means that we take the uh words or
phrases that are you know within
documents and we map them into numerical
vectors representing the meaning of
those words and phrases so we can have
word or phrase embeddings
but you can also do things like sentence
embeddings where you take an entire
sentence and try to map it into a vector
representing the meaning of the sentence
you can do the same thing with
paragraphs to create paragraph
embeddings a vector that you know
maps to the meaning of an entire
paragraph when taken as a whole and of
course you can take an entire document
and break up all of the pieces within
the document and try to map it to a
vector that represents the overall
meaning of the document
if you think of this in terms of the way
we think of an inverted index
historically
you know whereas you might have a query
that comes in so for example on the left
here these are query keywords you know
apple cheese juice etc
and then you have an inverted index like
we looked at before which has you know a
bunch of individual words mapped to
whether they exist within documents or
not
in this case
you could actually represent
a query for example the query for apple
as a vector where the vector has a 1 in
the position where apple exists and a 0
in every other position and the length
of this vector essentially has one
element for every possible word that
exists in any of your documents
this is known as one hot encoding
uh what you can then do if you represent
each query as a vector so apple has you
know one in the position for apple juice
has a one in the position for juice for
that feature then you can ultimately add
those two vectors together to get the
vector for apple juice where apple and
juice both appear this is similar to the
set intersection we saw a few minutes
ago with the inverted index
you can also do multi-term searches
using that technique so now apple and
juice has a one in both of these
positions we can you know think of this
vector as the query for apple juice
and so far these look almost identical
right we've got
our inverted index here mapping terms to
documents
and then over here we've got
you know queries
and the same thing happened over here
with the apple juice query and over here
we've got queries and we're mapping
those to vectors that represent you know
where they exist
but then the magic comes into play uh
with uh thought vectors with these
embeddings which is the idea of
dimensionality reduction so whereas
before we had one feature or
dimension in this vector for every
possible word what if we don't want to
have that many dimensions
we can apply dimensionality reduction so
that in this case instead of having um
each query map to the specific words
that it contains instead we have it
mapped to a reduced set of features
which describe
in some way uh the things we're
searching for so in this case i've
created eight different categories or
features
one of them being whether the query over
here
represent the term over here represents
food whether it represents you know
something you can drink whether it
contains dairy bread caffeine whether
it's sweet whether it has calories or
whether it's considered healthy
so you can see in this case for example
a donut is food it's not a drink it
contains a little bit of dairy contains
a lot of bread it is very sweet it
contains
the the highest number of calories of
everything on here and it's
not healthy at all
and you could you know see the rest map
to a similar space in terms of
how they map to these features
so once we've done that and we've
essentially represented all of our terms
or phrases
we create these vectors that we just saw
on the last screen that represent each
of those terms or phrases
these are known as our embeddings or our
thought vectors representing words and
phrases in this case
once we've done that we can take a
similarity between any two of these
vectors um you know using something like
a dot product or a cosine or you know
euclidean distance or any number of
similarity measures and ultimately we
generate similarity scores for each of
these so for example if i search for
cheese pizza
and i grab the
vector for cheese pizza and then i do a
cosine similarity between that vector
and all of these other vectors i can get
a ranked set of results showing me that
for example cheese breadsticks are the
most similar thing to cheese pizza
cinnamon breadsticks are the most
similar thing to or the second most
similar thing to cheese pizza and so on
with water being the least similar
um if i take green tea you'll see that
water and cappuccino and latte and then
apple juice are the most similar these
all have to do with being drinks going
from most healthy to least healthy and
then donut is the thing that is the
furthest away in terms of similarity
similarity to green tea
and so implementing this kind of vector
search those were simple examples we'll
do something more complicated in a
minute um requires dense vector
support in your search engine and so you
know all of the open source or at least
partially open source search engines
solar elastic surge vespa etc all
contain some level of vector dense
vector support
i'm
typically using solar so i'm going to
show you some examples of how to do this
with solar today
and
what one of the first ways is through
solar streaming expressions capabilities
and so
as an example
if i'm using streaming expressions i can
pass in documents where
these are the exact documents i was just
looking at
and i can pass in a vector i'm using a
multi-valued float field
where i just pass in each of the
dimensions as the the multiple values
going in
once i've done that
i can
use a streaming expression like this
where i'm selecting the top
um someone's at front door
apologies somebody just rang my doorbell
um
i can uh
search for the top
um from this query where i'm searching
for um my my food collection and trying
to do a cosine similarity
um with this vector
um you know this being a query for
actually the doughnut vector and do a
cosine similarity and what i see is that
the donut document is the most similar
to the donut vector followed by cinnamon
breadsticks and cheese pizza and so on
another thing that i could do is
i can search for
sorry another technique i can use if i
want to use a vector search in my main
line query not as a streaming expression
is to use
solar 14397 which is the vector fields
and functions in solar
patch that i'm personally currently
working on and i'll show you how to use
that
uh
so um same thing here if you you know
just want to pull the code you know
build solar and start solar
you create a collection once you've
created a collection you add your
uh you know dense vector field
type to your schema and then you create
an actual vector field so in this case
i'm naming my field vectors underscore v
making it a dense vector and um going
from there
once i've done that
then i
uh can add documents just like before
where i've got uh
you know
donut apple juice cappuccino cheese
pizza green tea
et cetera here's all my documents
um and one interesting thing to note and
the solar implementation here is that i
can actually pass in multiple vectors
per uh field within the document so in
this case um you know
when i do my vector similarity scoring
instead of being limited to one vector
per document which would be a document
thought vector or document embedding i
can actually um you know potentially do
you know a vector per paragraph or a
vector sentence or even a vector per
word
once i've done this i can now
come in and
you know run my search so in this case i
want to sort by and return the vector
similarity
so i've got my
in this case my query is going to be for
this
vector for uh that represents a doughnut
my cosine similarity function is here
this vector cosine function
i'm going to return
that cosine score and i'm going to sort
my results based upon that cosine
similarity calculation
so in this case when i search for the
donut vector what i get back is you know
the top result with a perfect score is
the donut document because this first
vector in that document got a perfect
score
cinnamon bread six are next cheese pizza
and and so on and so forth so this is an
example of using
the cosine similarity to score documents
based upon the similarity of the vectors
in this next example
i'm doing
something similar but instead of only
relying on the vector similarity
calculation i'm actually combining
the vector
similarity with traditional keyword
search so in this case i actually search
for the term bread
and
i i'm going to match that like a normal
keyword search and rank based upon the
the bm25 score for bread but then uh i'm
also going to boost the ranking of my
search results based upon the cosine
similarity between the vectors so in
this case you know same thing here's my
donut vector here's my cosine similarity
calculation
still returning the fields but in this
case i'm doing a boost based upon the
cosine similarity
and a normal query based upon bread and
so this case what you see is that
because i matched on the term bread in
my query that i only get the two
documents that contain the word bread
and them so cinnamon breadsticks and
cheese breadsticks but i'm actually
boosting because i searched on the
vector for doughnut i'm boosting on the
one that is the most related to donut in
this case cinnamon bread sticks is more
related to donut than cheese breadsticks
and you can see in the
explain down here for the calculation
that indeed it matched and did a bm25
score on this
term bread and then boosted based upon
the cosine similarity uh for uh the the
vectors
uh this next example um allows me to
essentially uh use the vector the cosine
similarity as the
uh score and um to actually
cut off the results beyond a certain
score so unlike bm25 i mean traditional
search relevancy which has all of the uh
the scores relative to each other where
there's no sort of absolute score uh
indicating uh the quality of the match
when you're doing something like a
vector similarity and cosine in this
case um the scores are actually more
absolute where a one is a perfect score
and a zero is you know no match at all
and so in this case what i'm doing is
i'm running my query uh my my query
itself is the cosine similarity value
that is calculated everything else in
here is exactly the same but now i'm
applying a filter which
limits the rate the documents coming
back to only documents that have greater
than 0.75 cosine similarity so in this
case
the results i get back are ordered by
relevance in this case the cosine
similarity score uh and they're
cut off so that no documents with a
score less than 0.75 come back so in
this case i only get my top ranked
documents donuts cinnamon bread sticks
cheese pizza and cheese bread sticks
so that should give you a general sense
of how to
implement uh you know once you've got
these thought vectors how to actually
implement them in apache solar but of
course those are all fairly contrived
examples using you know food items and
attributes of food
that's not a real world application and
i also came up with those categories by
hand so the question then becomes how do
i encode my documents and queries into
vectors
so
that's where vector encoders come in so
vector encoders take queries documents
documents sentences paragraphs etc and
transform them into thought vectors or
embeddings usually they leverage deep
learning which can discover rich
language usage rules and semantics and
then map them to combinations of
features in the vector and there's lots
of different libraries that do this
and to give you a sense of those
libraries i think everybody is pretty
familiar with word to beck came out in
2013 sort of took the nlp world by storm
um glove came out about a year later um
and improved upon what where tebec could
do
fast text a few years later
and then in 2017 uh the this paper um
about um all you need is attention came
out um to introduce transformers which
ultimately
took us a generation beyond what word to
beck and the others did where whereas
word tevec came up with a static
representation of a vector that
represented a you know a word what
transformers did is they took the idea
of context into consideration so that
words and phrases could have different
meaning within
the context in which they appeared and
so uh shortly thereafter we got elmo
we got the universal sims encoder which
didn't necessarily um use follow the
transformer model but then almost
everything you saw from that point on
leveraged the transformer model uln fit
really made transfer learning which is
the ability to start with a base
language model and then retrain only a
portion of it to
based upon the the content your domain
that's where it really became popular
here in these models and then of course
of course bert
was a the next major breakthrough you
know which google has leveraged very
heavily and then you know you can see
from that point on there's just been an
explosion of different models that have
come out
all of these you know not even
including anything that came into being
in 2020 lots of sesame street characters
that the theming is fun there but um but
that's sort of what we what we see now
and i haven't even included any of the
2020 stuff other than um i did want to
mention gpt3 which just came out
uh i think the beginning of june this
month uh which we'll talk about in just
a little bit um and you can actually see
this is the leaderboard for the glue
benchmark which is one of the benchmarks
that measures the success rates of each
of these models and half of these i
don't even recognize the the field is
just growing by leaps and bounds so
quickly
so we mentioned transformers uh which
most of the the modern models follow you
know what is a transformer a transformer
ultimately um allows you to uh take
incoming text so in this case i've got
she went for a walk outdoors to encode
it into a vector representation or an
embedding and then um
once i've done that i can take that
representation that in theory represents
the meaning of the the input and then
decode it back into something that's
more you know human understandable so in
this case i might get something out
like the woman went outside to walk if
my input was she went uh for a walk
outdoors the the meaning was sort of
communicated here and then re-translate
it back out
um you could also build a different
decoder so maybe i encoded this way but
then i had a decoder built for
the german language and i can
automatically get a translation out that
that is pretty good because the meaning
has been preserved in the embedding
uh the when we're doing search um
implementations and trying to do uh
similarity for search typically we don't
use the decoder part of the transformer
and we focus on just on the encoder and
so in this case documents will go into
the encoder and for each document i will
get um you know a document vector or
maybe a you know
paragraph vector sentence
vectors etc
um those all get indexed into the search
engine and then whenever a query comes
in i
uh you know similarly uh get the
embedding for it and then i do the
similarity calculation that i showed you
a few a few slides back um that allows
you to score each
uh query vector relevant to all of the
vectors represented in your documents
there's some performance considerations
however whenever we're doing this for
real-time search so for example
vector scoring is slow it's a
whereas with the traditional inverted
index you look up the documents that you
need to score and then only score those
with
vector similarities you have to actually
score every single document that you're
considering to figure out if it's a
match or not and so
this is equivalent to doing a table scan
in a database so it can be very very
expensive and very slow
so the solution vet to that is this
notion of quantized vectors or proxima's
nearest neighbors approximate nearest
neighbors
the idea here is that you map the
vectors into a set of discrete values
ultimately creating tokens that you can
put into your inverted index to match on
to reduce the number of documents that
you have to actually do the full vector
scoring
on and that enables you to really
combine vector scoring uh with
traditional search while not
being painfully slow
so the recommended approach when you're
implementing this in a search engine is
typically to
do approximate nearest neighbor search
leveraging one of these quantization
techniques and then after you've found a
potential candidate set of documents
that should be good matches you then
re-rank those documents leveraging the
vector similarity score
and so you know similarly in solar if
you want to implement this
um you know same general setup as before
except for um in this case i'm saying
that instead of scoring all of the
documents i only want to bring back the
top i only want to bring back the top
five documents that are returned and of
those five documents i'm then going to
run my
vector cosine similarity on those
so you can see my example here document
one the these first uh
i guess sorry i should probably should
have been four um but these top
documents um have a higher score because
they've been re-ranked and for my donut
search you see that donut cheese pizza
apple juice and cappuccino were the top
ranked out of those uh first five that
came back and then you can see that
um things the typo should be four but um
and then you can see that for the rest
of the documents they just appear in you
know document order because they didn't
actually get scored
and so in practice you know i just did a
wild card search here to show the
technique but in practice
if you've got a
mechanism to either do an initial
keyword search essentially as your
approximate nearest neighbor query or to
build some approximate nearest neighbors
or clustering capability that you can
then tag on the documents so that you
can then uh filter on them before the
scoring uh you would just you know pass
in the a n filter as either your query
if there's some relevance associated
with it or just as a filter if you just
want to filter down to a candidate set
of documents and then re-rank them
so there's lots of different approximate
nearest neighbors approaches
this gives you an example of
you know some of the benchmarks there
are several
that are currently in the process of
being implemented in apache leucine so
i'm actually having vector fields and
leucine
that internally can implement
approximate nearest neighbors indexing
to make a search faster i'm not going to
go over those but definitely check them
out
um and then of course there's you know
some limitations for these embedding
models so um this article you know we
talked looked at earlier about bert um
one of the things i didn't mention
before is that um it actually only is
being used by google in one one out of
ten searches
so
it's not a
solution to solve every problem but in
one out of ten searches uh it is uh
you know so ninety percent of searches
are still using other techniques
um additionally um
uh
you know the search companies google
said that bert the burt technique would
return more useful responses to many
queries but it also said that in summons
this is the new algorithm had produced
worse results than before so um it
doesn't necessarily always
improve things
further gpt-3 which just came out at the
beginning of june
um is a major breakthrough there's
something like 175 billion parameters
that use this to train but in the paper
they actually identify some general
issues with the use of these kind of
language models
so for this article in this article says
despite the strong quantitative and
qualitative improvements of gpt-3
it still has notable weaknesses those
weaknesses include an inability to
achieve significant accuracy on
adversarial nli which is um you know
where programs need to determine the
relationship between two sentences
gpt 3 does little better than chance on
things like adversarial nli the author's
right worse having amped up the
processing power to 175 billion weights
the authors weren't exactly sure why it
was coming up short
additionally and even more startling is
the next observation the whole practice
of trying to predict what's going to
happen with language
may be the wrong approach um and uh you
know these may be the wrong types of
models for this
and so if you look at traditional
keyword search versus vector search
uh we can actually note a few
throughout a few examples where where
each one is likely to do well or to fail
so for example
for obscure keyword combinations like
this boolean query keyword search does
really well and vector search completely
fails
for specific identifiers and attributes
for example somebody searching for a
specific product or attribute a keyword
search will succeed because it's just
filtering down on known um
attributes whereas vector search will
likely fail depending upon how it was
trained and whether there's overfitting
or not for natural language queries like
can my spouse drive on my insurance
keyword search might get lucky but it's
probably going to fail pretty miserably
because it doesn't understand the words
whereas vector search will succeed
fuzzy language queries like famous
french tower are things that keyword
search will mismatch because it again is
just looking at individual keywords but
where vector search will um will succeed
but then you've got this this issue of
structured relationship queries so
things like popular barbecue near near
paystack
where you actually have meaning
associated with each of these and you're
looking at the interrelationship between
them
in this case keyword search will fail
and vector search will fail because
vector search won't necessarily know
that hey stack is a um as an event at a
particular location and i'm looking for
a geospatial search
for you know trying to do all these
relationships just
vector search just doesn't quite pull it
off
and so um you know that's where we get
into knowledge graphs um and i'm going
to skip over this sort of what is a
knowledge graph piece of it but there's
one particular kind of knowledge graph
that i've worked on called a semantic
knowledge graph
that essentially
allows us to take the keywords that we
have in our documents and
relate them statistically to try to
figure out other related keywords i've
presented on this in the past so i'm not
going to spend much time on it today but
i can essentially take a term
look through documents to find other
related terms and then you know sort of
traverse through the graph that way
and so uh one way i've used this um and
since this is a
remote conference i didn't have a
location so i used a previous conference
that i spoken at which is
activate but what i can actually do is
query the semantic knowledge graph or
query my inverted index and ask it
questions like hey what does barbecue
mean and what it can tell me is that hey
based upon the content in my inverted
index barbecue is most related to the
category of document of restaurant
and within that category um you know it
means things like barbecue brisket and
ribs and pork
and the second most common category is
outdoor equipment and within that
category
bbq is related to things like grill
charcoal and propane
i can then combine that with a
structured knowledge graph so in this
case
my query for barbecue or activate
i can do things like say you know let me
search for let me find the word near see
that that's related to location distance
traverse from there to you know activate
which is the conference
figure out that activate is um
was when it was last held at the was
held at the washington hilton and then
you know the the washington hilton i can
look up a location for that and so this
is an example i'm not going to go
through the details but an example of me
taking the keyword activate and mapping
it using a knowledge after reversal and
solar to the location that activate was
held at
and then um you know this example again
the slides will be available afterwards
allows me to take that keyword of
barbecue look that up in the semantic
knowledge graph we did just a minute ago
take the keyword of activate do one
query to solar to traverse the knowledge
graph and ultimately bring back a search
um
build a search query that actually goes
to solar
that looks like barbecue ribs brisket
dot type of restaurant and then
filtering to the location that activate
was held at and all of that can be done
with one graph you know lookup in the
knowledge graph and then a subsequent
query to actually rank the results um
similarly you know it's query for top
bbq in berlin realizes that top actually
means a you know
a boost on popularity of documents and
then everything else here is very
similar to before
and we talked about the transformer
models before and where context really
matters i mean in this case you know you
can see that when i search for barbecue
near activate
that it understands that i'm looking for
a restaurant but if i search for
barbecue grill it understands a
different meaning of the words and also
that grill is a sort of outdoor
appliance and the the category of grill
and so the the same kind of nuance that
we get with
thought vectors and these transformer
models we can actually get through our
knowledge graphs as well if we construct
them appropriately
and so and with a knowledge graph
approach answering a a query like
four-star hotels near movie theaters
open after midnight in berlin is
something we can handle pretty easily
whereas with either keyword search or
thought vectors that would be
challenging
and so um you know just a couple of
thoughts um here as we wrap up on um
semantic vector spaces so thought
vectors are embeddings
knowledge graphs and keyword search
ultimately all resolve to the same
overlapping semantic vector spaces we're
still dealing with the same content and
the same relationships within the the
meaning of the things in our domain it's
just these are different
representations or techniques we can use
to get at that understanding
at the semantics
each of these are really just different
ways of looking at the same
relationships that exist within our
content
likewise it's also possible to model
user behavior signals into either
numerical vectors tokens on documents or
as nodes and edges in a graph again each
of these techniques can be used both for
content and for user behavior
and finally certain types of attributes
are much easier to represent as
numerical vectors such as image features
and things like that this makes
multimodal learning or joint learning
much easier to accomplish than in the
past with just keywords and knowledge
graphs
and so if you sort of think of this as
different approaches if i take a query
like this one here machine learning
research and development portland oregon
software engineer and youtube java
traditional keyword search would
represent it this way a knowledge graph
based query might expand that based upon
the relationships that it understands
and a thought vector would ultimately
try to map the entire query into
one
a vector of meaning and try to search on
that to probabilistically find the
results
um i like to think of things in terms of
the
when we're solving search problems in
terms of
our ultimate goal being to understand
user intent which ultimately means
understanding our content understanding
our users and understanding our domain
um you know knowledge graphs and keyword
search are key ways that we we do that
um and i like to think of you know dense
vector search not as a new dimension but
essentially as a technique so we can use
the inverted index
to match on tokens we can use dense
vector search to
score and then match based upon high
scores or we can use a hybrid approach
which i showed earlier when you're
trying to combine both together
and so a couple of takeaways
first thought vectors or embeddings work
very well for natural language queries
and questions or for modeling
non-textual data like image features and
user signals dense vectors also make it
easier to enable joint learning modeling
text content user behavioral signals
images and so on
to a shared vector space but keep in
mind that even google only uses this
technique currently for 10 of their
queries
knowledge graphs on the other hand work
best for relational queries including
reasoning about known entities dealing
with hierarchies and multi-level
inference
keyword search is not dead it works best
for long tail keywords specific item or
attribute search like names and ids
obscure keywords boolean type query
needs and is the safest catch-all or
fallback for most queries
and then finally it should be possible
to actually enable explainable ai on
train dense vector representations
by mapping similar documents back to
overlapping semantic vector spaces at
the keyword and attribute level
such as through the semantic knowledge
graph i showed earlier essentially
if we understand that each of these
techniques is ultimately trying to get
at the same semantics in the same
semantic
space
and vector space then we should in
theory be able to overlap these
techniques on top of each other and use
one to explain the other and so that's
an area that i personally plan to spend
some time researching
in the near future
so i think at the end of the day the
best systems will likely use a
combination of all these approaches
blended together
and hopefully more
to come soon on on all of that
um so that's it for me uh thank you uh
charlie if you want to um i don't know
if we have any questions if we've got a
couple of minutes maybe take a few of
those um but yeah thank you everybody